in honor of tonight's finale of flash we
are here with one of my favorite people
on the planet friend of the show friend
of the coy Jessica Parker Kennedy how're
you doing hi friend Cory welcome thank
you I'm so excited to talk flash you
were here for like the season premiere
so we're bucking the flash so what like
well thank you for having me back this
is such a wonderful welcome I feel so
included I love that we can shape the
season around like this conversation
absolutely it's such an honor to be here
to eight to be able to bookend it in
that light all right last time you were
here it was like are you excited to be a
big part of the season turns out you
were a big part of the season yeah just
a little big part yeah yeah how's that
been going
the big takeaway boy oh boy it's been
incredible I've had an amazing amazing
ten months I've worked with some of my
most favorite people and I've met
lifelong friends and it's been so much
work which has been awesome that's like
an actor's number one favorite thing to
say is that like I'm so tired there's a
bit unsaid so much thing to be able to
say now this season is very dense and
every season of flash is dense but this
has so much time travel like continuity
and especially around you when you first
got brought onto the project did you
know the big character twist was coming
was that part of the introduction with
Nora yeah I knew most of what was gonna
be happening in the season not
absolutely everything but a lot of it
I didn't realize Nora would be messing
up quite so often just causing a lot of
chaos in the season which was just a
delightful surprise she's just a silly
kid that doesn't know what she's doing
he's very good at messing up timelines
too so just following in his footsteps
really that's why he can never get mad
at me exactly he like does for a second
and then he's like it's okay I did the
same thing now selfishly I I had the
amazing experience of joining up in
Vancouver to see some of this get film
yeah yes these stories it's very unique
to be like I was there as blankety-blank
and it was really cool to see the sheer
amount of dialogue that goes into a
scene I was so impressed it they usually
have that two to three pages for a movie
three to four for TV this was
like a soap-opera amount but not soap
opera acting it's crazy and I have to
ask how you in particular you can cry
and stop crying and come play a card
game in like 12 seconds just because I
was so stressful no yeah so we'll do
people that have the hardest freaking
dialogue on the whole show danielle
panabaker and Carlos Valdez because they
have the sciency talk and the stuff that
they have to memorize in the speed they
have to memorize it within and then the
speed that they have to speak it is
ridiculous
yeah so they're my heroes but yeah those
big cortex scenes where we're all there
is just it's it's utter chaos and their
little longest scenes I kind of like
them because they're contained and I get
to work with all the actors at the same
time so for me that's really fun as
opposed to like being in the forest in
the middle of the night at 4 o'clock in
the morning which we also do sometimes -
I talked about forests and I forgot your
question how do you turn Norah on and
off so yeah I don't know I feel I flaky
we're working really long hours and
we're really tired so it's really easy
to cry and it's easy to act like a child
and Norah's like very childlike so I
think that all it but part and parcel
that works really well and yeah you do
your scene you do your thing and then
you go play cards with your friends on
the side and it was great and we all
learned a new card game yeah a forced n
yeah talk to us by Carlos Valdes and
Carlos I love that there was a scene
being filmed but but Carlos and Candice
would like the game was such a thing
that yeah yeah it felt like the dial the
dialogue was though important yes
important yeah there was a lot of like
running back to play the card game in
between takes and this sounds very much
like sort of classic theatre actors who
are just sort of you all of the great
theatre stories are people being like
and then they walked through the wings
and it was on and they walked back off
and it was all well I think - because
they've been doing it for five seasons
it's like they can it's just easy for
them now it's like they can do it in
their sleep so not that like being on
set doesn't have its challenging moments
obviously it does but it's easy for them
to be like character and now me and I'm
in character and I'm playing card games
so it's quite impressive and when you
were here at the beginning of the season
we talked with the family aspect to the
flash cast because I was really
impressed a comic-con of how everyone
was just like shorthand and like really
a family and loving and caring and on
set it's even more so I'm
ever been on a set that was literally a
family reunion now that you've done a
full season with these folks have
anything changed any perspectives any
like any crazy high drinks I mean yeah
there are high jinks like there was the
day that Tom Cavanaugh who's the most
let's just say the most mature and he
brought a ball set brought a ball
brought a little red ball to play with
and so while other people were working
he was in the back trying to throw the
ball at grant and grant would have to
like catch it while Carlos was doing his
scene
needless to say Carlos to find it very
funny but and grant really didn't either
but I've got Walden which is hilarious
I was gonna bring up that story but I
was there for this whole you were there
feather hauls are so echoey so you're
just you're like blah blah blah blah
science was awesome it was hilarious
grant would be like don't table no no
and then grant would have to catch it
cuz if you didn't catch it it would
bounce and then it would ruin the take
it was just and i like danielle
Panabaker and i were in the back just
going like oh my gosh
boys are children all they are boys are
boys are children lots of very silly
hijinks going on on the show for sure
so if you're a fan of the show and you
wonder how that energy and that fun is
captured the show is that like if I'm
seen on camera off camera I'm Sicilian
is what was the biggest surprise for you
getting a script since you guys you knew
the shape of the show but was there any
twist that happened this season that
surprised you yes
I can't talk about it oh I was hoping
twist big twist a big moment that made
you really happy I don't know I just I
want to see something so exciting and um
but I just feel like everything has just
been really special and I've loved every
minute of it um I I don't know I think I
maybe not script wise but relying on
grant and Candice to actually be kind of
my mom and dad on set was a really big
kind of thing I wasn't expecting at all
it was very much written that way in the
script of course and then I found myself
like days that I had to be a superhero
and grant wasn't on set full-blown
full-blown panic I was like my dad gotta
do this race grant yeah so you're like
you know metaphorically I held my hand
through a lot of in Saudi Canada so you
you were telling us a story would about
like one member of the cast that it was
sort of maybe potentially intimidating
at first
yeah Kavanagh when I met Kavanagh he I
was quite afraid of him just because he
Cavanaugh is one of the silliest people
I have ever met in my entire life but
when you first meet him sometimes he is
a bit on guard so it took me I was just
like world it was just very exciting and
then he was like I have 11 children and
I was like oh my god you're this and it
was one is like when you are in school
and he's like the coolest person in
school and all you want to do is be
friends with him and you have to like
work your way and it didn't take very
long to work my way in but yeah and then
he just you're like oh you're the
silliest goofiest person in the entire
world and then you just have a
ridiculous time with him and now he's
like my big brother so if you could plan
out a couple of things that there wasn't
time for an order to do this year
what would she have ducked out and done
um I wanted to have adventures so badly
with Cisco's character because he's one
of my favorite characters on the show so
I feel like that I would have loved for
like noir to go get in trouble and
Francisco to be there with it and um and
did need to I love that character and I
wish I could have spent more time in the
season like having yeah spending time
with them and and and solving monsters
[Laughter]
that we will plan that for our fan
fiction like loss adventures a very
similar question if you had the powers
of Nora what would you do in your
regular life differently
well I'm chronically 10 minutes late for
everything so I feel like if I had that
speed the including and how much
everyone's triggered yeah so I probably
wouldn't be late anymore or my time
management skills would be exactly the
same and like if I needed to be
somewhere at 11 I would probably leave
the house as an or like I'm 15 yeah
exactly we can get more done on the
journey to the 10 absolutely
yeah I run all my errands grocery
shopping for me it'd be the big change I
think I'd be amazing to like grocery
shop in like 30 seconds and then like
the calorie deficit would be amazing
like I have some nutrition goals of
flashback you'd be like more fit than
you are now I just feel like exactly
I despise grocery shopping so much so
that would be that's a wonderful way to
use it in and out done list that's the
only part of girl shopping I like is
writing the list cuz you and me are both
liars we enjoy writing a list but I
don't like doing this we run into each
other at the grocery store and listen
very very important yes no I love that
this season felt like another leap in
not just the quality of the show but the
way that the propulsion of the show like
the way than the show is going of force
with speed in it just without giving
anything away is there anything in the
finale that lends itself to be like
there's something coming next season
that would is there a giant tease the
end of the season without giving away
what that tease is that's gonna reshape
the flash yeah that's the answer I was
kind of expected together but I had to
ask the question because I love finales
oh yes officially no particular reason
to be excited about this one that's all
I got thanks guys alright see you next
time
- black sails yeah both are very family
cast both are very different tone what
was the difference in like set flavor
like mmm it could not in a lot of ways
be more different I would say just so
that because this this sort of scale of
black sails was so intense and the
distances we had to travel to shoot
location shoot so that sort of stuff and
just the sheer uncomfortableness of all
of us being in wigs and crazy costumes
and the heat of South Africa where we
shot it we were all super super super
close so it's definitely like her
friends for life actually just on Claire
Padgett who plays aunt Bonnie the other
day and I saw Zac the other day and I'm
literally seeing Tom Hopper today who
played Billy bones so good number L
Academy I even seen it is awesome
I can't wait yeah he's blowing up yeah
really like blowing up I designed it for
him
he's very talented man and very silly
and does the most amazing impressions of
anyone I've ever met ever it's like
extraordinary he's so gifted he should
have a Netflix like stand up just for
his impressions really it's truly
entertaining yeah it's just a different
a different tone entirely because the
two shows are such different tones and
you know to a dialogue on on the flash
is one thing and then dialogue on black
cells was like a whole they're like five
pages of monologues every single day of
your life there were the most thoughtful
Pirates of all say they just thought and
thought they'd be they need the eye but
it was like that the metaphors and very
articulate well-read puppet-like
soliloquies it's funny so with it with
the season in in the can now how did you
find like was there a journey with the
action of it did it come immediately to
you or like what was it like doing the
action stuff on this which I imagine is
unlike anything yeah so I am horrible
speedster in real life I'm a terrible
Runner the blooper reel just came out
for us to see the one with all the the F
words in it which we edited down for the
rest of the world and the amount of
times that I go the wrong direction fall
mid-run is like shock no it's not
shocking to me but it's like shocking
for someone who has to play a speedster
I got a lot every of the fans have been
so incredibly positive about my
character except for my run was quite
hated a lot of the time I apologize
profusely but I yeah so we need to maybe
it's work on my my running skills
slightly I feel like my fight scenes
were really good that I had to do
occasionally but my running you know get
good like cuz he looks like grant looks
so cool when he does all of his action
stuff and his running stuff mixed with
like facial expressions he like is the
flash where I was just like well trying
my best and failings funny like he's the
flesh like I really liked oh he embraces
the the flash slotted three in real life
like it's just yeah he's very much as in
a way kind of like that character now
you reference fan reaction to your
character what
like to see that go out in the world to
be part of this family so nice so when I
was at Comic Con where Ulta ran into coy
San Diego last year I was doing a
roundtable interview and this random
interviewer asked me one question and he
said are you ready for the scrutiny and
we had we barely started and I was
terrified after that because I always
you know comic fans are very intense
people you're passionate to be so
passionate about something so when
you're playing a character that's based
on a comic character but then is like if
not that comic characters like a mix of
characters and different people I was a
little bit afraid and then when he said
that I became terrified and then for the
most part other than occasional like
eight-year-olds that have been like
nobody likes you go hold back where you
came from like that the occasional like
little messages I get which like
actually make me like feel I don't know
like warms my heart even though they're
negative because they're really funny
people have been really really positive
towards me and really welcoming and said
really nice things so I felt very
welcomed amongst the actors and and that
and on set and then very welcome in the
world of comic humans I'm so glad to
hear that how was that world change you
were on Smallville back when this was
just beginning like comic books were not
as widespread as it was like oh that's
the the making a comic show it was a big
deal now there's 30 and then you were a
Secret Circle so you've dabbled in that
world like a couple times how was it
evolved since yeah I'm so glad that it
has evolved mostly I feel that evolution
going to Comic Cons you know because the
fans are so intense and so enthusiastic
I've had people like meet me and cry and
I've been like please don't cry so that
that that's just been I don't know I
just love that because I understand it I
mean everybody knows by now I'm a really
big Buffy fan so if anyone feels
anything about the characters that I've
been able to play in these different
shows the way that I feel about my Buffy
life you know it's a it's a huge deal so
I feel very happy to be a part of it who
won Buffy would know where I get along
with and who would she hate
I feel like she would get along with
everybody
Tara was kind of annoying I don't know
maybe she would she would like be
annoyed fights her but then he little
think they'd be like best friends - I
don't know Yin initial cross wires and
then the bonding yeah okay maybe like
spike maybe like initially because more
would be really little you know she
would like want to like like punch spike
call it maybe something like in asleep
taught me or something and I your beer
Buffy parallel to me Buffy directly
inspired Smallville down to the coffee
shop and then to me flash like jitters
is directly from the Buffy coffees like
the flavor of flash to me is very black
Buffy I know they even refer to
themselves as the Scooby Gang which they
did on Buffy all the time you know and
they do it on the flash constantly so
did you have that moment of fulfillment
or you're like I'm in this generations
like you've got you're in that world
show you know in a way in a way to me
it's not quite you know that like I
still envision myself like the way I
look at Buffy I was in that show I was
like a character I was like angels
sister from something so I'm like well
no no no it's not that cuz I wasn't even
though it kind of was in my brain but
yeah there's an element of it hundred
percent where I'm like I am kind of in
that world like I am it's the same
network basically like a you know I mean
it was it is very cool like if I got
talking to that 13 year old version of
myself to be like you're gonna be in a
show like this referring to yourself as
this goofy like it is definitely surreal
and very exciting now the comic this
week actually this past week issue
seventy is the year one story so it
retails his origins and it's very much
like the show like some of the frames
are actually looking like the way the CW
frames flash like Barry Allen feels like
grant is there anything you would love
to see Nora get translated into the
comics from your take is there anything
you did that you'd like to see oh that's
such a good question and I like
literally my heart sped up because I was
like please answer this well please as
well because I know comic comic people
are listening um I don't know it'd be so
much more interested to hear what they
would want me I just I think I'd like a
I'll focus on what an incredible Runner
I am because
so in the comics it would be like wow
she is better than her father the
abilities of her caption box
extraordinary really better than we've
ever seen any speedster before yeah
that's what I need I always ask actors
especially ones that I love their work
and your stuff in flash like truly even
like as a friend and as a viewer of the
flash what else do you want to do like
what's the next thing you want to do
like a Broadway play do you want to do
like a drama do Sorkin I wanted you all
of it I want to do Sorkin I want to do
Broadway I want to do drum I want to do
comedy I don't want to do absolutely
everything I've got so much so much to
give yeah there's something acting is a
really glorious cathartic experience and
and I think being able to dabble in all
genres is an important thing to be able
to do even if you fall flat on your face
and are terrible it's you got to try
everything it's like Johnny Depp just
does absolutely everything and most of
the time we love him and sometimes we're
like oh and it's just mad respect every
single time whether it's amazing or it's
not so I just want to I want to do that
do you have a favorite moment that we
saw or one that we didn't get to see
because it was behind the scenes from
this year mm oh I hope that you get to
see me falling so in the 100th episode
that Tom Cavanagh directed there is a
scene where grant and I would cuz we
sort of do this freeze thing before run
and I was in these platform sneakers and
we were on a hill and every single time
and we're both like in black and looking
like really cool anchor and we'd go we
get and run and we get into this
position and freeze and grant would
freeze and then run off and I would
freeze and literally go it happened 10
20 times ridiculous and it's in the
blooper reel so that's all I hope I hope
that that makes it onto the Internet so
everyone sings the leg is genuine
usually if it's you you don't laugh but
I was like well that's actually really
funny I'm an idiot
so with the once again I'm not trying to
get a tease for the end of the episode
yeah but with the finale airing tonight
is
anything you would say from this full
season experience leading up to the
finale you'd want people to know that
someone might not from just the footage
ne ne T's for tonight from your set
experience that you want to like I'm
talking like the first minute of the
show not the last minute for in the
first minute of the show safe a Safety's
a Safety's well I'll be in it will be in
it
Candice Patton will be there Valdez will
be there I'm gonna say all of the
characters from the show are in the
finale that's the safest ease I like it
they're all they're part of the beauty
of the show is that you literally can
just say the cast of flash will be there
and we're like I'm in yeah yeah like
right now how nice is that they're all
so good they were all cast so perfectly
for the show they really were my person
they were like thank you so much for
being here again on here oh you for
having me I love this season I love the
show and I think it's very important
that even if you fall on your face like
Nora and episode 100 and other episodes
you keep doing creative stuff make
awesome art thank you so much for
joining us and I can't wait to see
tonight's episode until next week guys
stay sweaty